so what Hogwart house does your favorite
Disney character belong in today we're
playing at being the Sorting Hat and
deciding will it be Gryffindor or do
they actually belong in Slytherin Elsa
is a bit of a tricky one to sort out to
be honest some might be tempted to place
her in Slytherin considering how
questionable her motivation seems but
when you really get down to it she is
totally devoted to her sister and
because of this we would have to place
her more with Hufflepuff seriously her
loyalty goes to such extremes that she's
even willing to isolate herself against
the world completely all to keep Anna
safe Elsa wait no I'm just trying to
protect you not only that but she's
hard-working and loyal to Arendale as
our Queen I took an oath to always do
what's best for Arendelle but she's
willing to give up the throne to Anna in
the sequel luckily I know just what that
is so while studying at Hogwarts Elsa
would definitely do well in a
transfigurations class seeing she's
already great at bringing plain snow to
life and of course she'd have to have
her sister Anna there every step of the
way now Anna's loyalty to her sister may
seem like a total Hufflepuff trait but
she shows off more than enough courage
to prove that gryffindor's red and gold
are her true Hogwarts colors like she
sets off on an adventure after years of
being shut up inside her family's castle
and that certainly takes a lot of
Courage I pushed her so I'm the one that
needs to go after like the girl accepts
any icy danger that's thrown her way all
with the goal of saving Arendale and
making sure that her people will have
their rightful ruler so you're not at
all afraid of her why would I be and
like seeing how courageous she is I can
definitely see Anna excelling in defense
against the dark arts while at Hogwarts
it is not nice to throw people feisty
pants and like Anna isn't the only
Disney princess who wants to be where
the people are like poor or Ariel girl
went through a lot it takes courage to
sell your voice to the sea witch and
start a completely new life on land
especially when everyone you know is
telling you not to Arya what are you
doing here
I'm going to see Ursula so like Ariel's
Disobedience towards tradition and
intentions of making her own path
definitely reminds us of a certain boy
who live I'm 18 years old and Prince
Eric totally would have been sunk a few
times were it not for Ariel saving his
life like all the time all things
considered Ariel is totally a Gryffindor
like her favorite class at Hogwarts
would definitely be muggle studies
seeing as she's already collecting
gadgets and gizmos of Plenty one thing
in the Box
I got 20. sort of like a certain father
of the Weasley family what exactly is
the function of a rubber duck and
speaking of princesses who are dreaming
of Adventure in the Great Wide somewhere
Belle's intelligence and creativity may
seem to place her in Ravenclaw but her
real defining moment comes when she's
willing to sacrifice herself for her
father this moment shows that she has an
almost Hufflepuff level of loyalty but
you also have to consider that something
like this requires a lot of Bravery to
do especially when her capture looks
like this she's foreign
well look at me plus when you consider
the one thing that she's like always
dreamed of we're saying that Bell is one
thousand percent Gryffindor she would
excel at like any Hogwarts class that
she tried to take on but she would
especially shine in history of magic or
maybe the study of ancient runes really
just anything that requires like a lot
of reading like is Belle another student
who may benefit from a Time Turner this
is how I've been getting to my lessons
all year she'd most definitely be
studying hard alongside one princess
who's training to be Sultan like
Princess Jasmine is willing to do
whatever it takes for her to win right
even if it means using herself as a
weapon against Jafar what street rat and
not to mention the live-action remake
Builds on her ambition by making it
clear that she wants to become Sultan
Breaking Free of tradition in order to
push forward for ambition I was born to
do more than marry some useless Prince
and like her ability to sneak out to the
marketplace without being recognized
proves that she's pretty cunning and
resourceful as well all of this just has
to make her a strong Contender for
Slytherin house Jasmine's interest in
people and culture suggests that she'd
probably Ace her history of magic
glasses while at Hogwarts but we can
also see her being a mean addition to
slytherin's Quidditch team playing as
either a chaser or a keeper against a
princess who's definitely Brave so
Merida's denying tradition by refusing
to accept a prince at all and I'll be
shooting for my own hand and although
her stubbornness and tendency towards
rash decisions can sometimes get her in
trouble like say the time she turned her
mother into a bear it's not my fault I
didn't ask her to change you into a beer
she's constantly driven by a need to do
what's right at the end of the day
because of this I'm gonna have to sort
Merida into Gryffindor House I mean come
on it's even the title of her own movie
She's Brave Merida is definitely the
princess that you'd want to find on your
Quidditch team either play plan as a
beater or a chaser and she'd discover
this passion in flying class similar to
Harry now if only she could find a way
to keep all that hair from getting
tangled while flying painting baking
ventriloquy or like candle making is
there anything this princess can't do
like she may be fair enough to roll with
the hufflepuffs but it's her creativity
that makes her a perfect addition to
Ravenclaw House Rapunzel's imagination
is what inspires her to break out from
mother gothel's control and like try to
learn about the broader World Beyond her
Tower I want to see the floating light
it's her curiosity and willingness to
learn about everything that makes her
such a good friend to everyone she meets
when it comes to Rapunzel's favorite
class at Hogwarts her ability to get
along with Maximus suggests that she'd
be like really good at care of magical
creatures oh he's nothing but a big
sweetheart but her many talents suggests
that she just like excel at every
subject right and seeing how she handles
her handy dandy frying pan she'd even
make an excellent beater in quidditch
playing against the savior of China
honestly Mulan is another tricky one she
may have disguised herself through most
of the movie which is something of a
Slytherin trait and her intense loyalty
to her father may even make her a
contender for Hufflepuff but her courage
is definitely worth a member of
Gryffindor House like she was risking
her life if she was discovered and yet
that still didn't make her pause from
taking her father's place in the Chinese
Army but like in fact she was even
willing to go back after everyone had
found out her big secret you said you
trust ping
why is Mulan any different and like not
only that but Mulan pushed herself to
become the best among her Fleet even
when she started out with less fighting
experience than like anyone else there
and if those aren't Gryffindor traits
then we don't know what is so obviously
Mulan would be the best in defense
against the dark arts class like
considering she's already proven herself
as the woman who saved all of China that
little baby is all grown up and saved in
China but when it comes to potions class
Mulan may just want a bit of help from a
certain froggy princess like Tiana is
one ambitious gal she's willing to do
whatever it takes to fulfill her dreams
of opening a restaurant right down to
kissing a frog I reckon you wanna kiss
she's ambitious and a go-getter and
these are all traits that prove she's a
classic Slytherin even buying a rundown
building of her restaurant won't get her
down cause she knows that she's
resourceful enough to make something out
of it and hang up on this
all work all the time attitude may make
her come across as cold when you first
meet her girl oh ever do his work but
when she considers someone to be a part
of her family she'll be loyal to the end
so Tiana's favorite Hogwarts class might
just have to be potions seeing as it's
closest to her passion of cooking and
baking and her least favorite definitely
transfigurations after the whole frog
Adventure we would definitely be
interested to see how far she'd go while
at Hogwarts Moana is hard-working and
loyal to her people like a Hufflepuff
but even so like she's still brave
enough to take on taka alone and even
stands up to the great demigod Maui you
are not my hero and because of this we
have to place her in Gryffindor
especially when you consider her strong
desire for adventure which characterizes
nearly every moment that she's on screen
like girl Braves terrible ocean storms
and massive shiny Crustaceans without
once losing sight of her goal and you
will restore the heart even Maui's
active attempt to frighten her don't
worry it's a lot farther down than it
looks and never enough to talk Moana out
of doing what she wants
and so moana's love for sailing may just
suggest that she'd do well in hogwarts's
astronomy class but we could also see
her scoring some major points as a
beater on gryffindor's Quidditch team so
what do you think about these sorting
choices would you agree with my reasons
for placing them like I did or do you
think there's a Hogwarts house that may
suit these Disney characters more
honestly we'd love to hear your thoughts
so make them heard in the comment
section down below okay